report now
because dave merritt the father of jack
merritt
is making a statement
[Applause]
jack merritt our son was a good man
doing good work
helping people less fortunate than him
to improve their education and their
self-esteem
through the learning together programme
from the university of cambridge
following his death we received many
letters from serving and former
prisoners
he had worked with telling us how jack
had a positive impact on their lives
jack understood the factors that had led
many of the people he worked with to end
up in prison
and he understood the value of kindness
and friendship in helping damaged people
repair their lives
jack would have described himself
proudly as woke
the opposite by definition being
ignorant
jack was a do-gooder in the very best
sense of that term
[Applause]
this inquest has answered many of our
questions about how
jack came to be killed it's clear to us
that the arrangements put in place for
managing usman khan
after his release from prison in 2019
were not fit for purpose
despite the authorities having had six
years to plan for this from the time his
sentence was changed
from an indeterminate sentence to an
extended sentence in 2013.
the mapper process did not operate
effectively
roles and responsibilities were unclear
communication between the agencies was
inadequate
and leadership and coordination were
weak
probation and police teams directly
responsible for khan's supervision
were staffed by officers with little or
no experience of terrorism offenders
the security services and west midlands
counterterrorism police were complacent
and passive in the face of khan's
extreme and continuing threat
we welcomed the changes implemented by
the probation service in the management
of terrorism offenders post release
specialist teams with a focus on
terrorism smaller caseloads
specialist training and experienced
officers and with access to
psychological analysis of offenders as
necessary
we hope that all other agencies and
organizations involved with khan
will learn the lessons highlighted by
the inquest
and will make changes to their systems
and working practices as appropriate
jack believed in the work he was doing
with prisoners through learning together
he saw firsthand the transformative
effect it had on the lives
of prisoners and students alike we
support the work of learning together
and we hope it continues in future with
due regard to the issues highlighted by
this inquest
we are sorry for saskia's family next to
whom we have stood in solidarity and
sorrow
throughout this process
we would like to thank our legal team
kate maynard
nick armstrong jesse nichols and lizzie
norton
for their expertise their humanity and
their good humor
they have helped us through the most
difficult and traumatic time of our
lives
thank you also to dci brown of the
metropolitan police's counter-terrorism
unit
and his team for an extremely thorough
and professional
investigation and for his kindness and
support
thank you to toby and sue our police
family liaison officers
who have been with us from the start and
who could not have been kinder or more
considerate
we'd like to thank the coroner his honor
judge loucraft qc
council to the inquest mr hoff qc and
his team for their professionalism
in managing this very long and complex
inquest
finally thank you to the members of the
jury for giving up your time
and for all your hard work thank you